so I've been trying to figure out probe
the faint disk wire the source of my
ills I've been on a quest you could say
to try to understand what is holding me
back what continues to get in my way
what keeps me kicking and screaming so
to speak what is this fear of being
fully alive as reading Ernest Becker's
book the denial of death in which he
cited the work of psychologist Abraham
Maslow and all of the steps towards
self-actualization that human beings
need to take one of the things that he
says is that we get a thrill from the
godlike possibilities that we see in
ourselves during our most perfect
moments yet we simultaneously shiver at
those very same possibilities there is a
kind of terror of being fully alive
there is this fear of kind of quaking
annihilating glory deterring our most
perfect moments when we feel the most
connected the most powerful when we're
actually in a state of surrender when we
let it all go we take our hands off the
wheel the ecstasy is so great we fear it
will undo us we fear we will not survive
past the ecstasy and so we shrink back
from being fully alive we shrink away
from life right we shy
from the sunlight we fear the intensity
of unfiltered experience and there is a
name for this affliction
it's called Jonah syndrome right the
fear of being fully alive right a
shrinking away from the full intensity
of life it is the feeling that it is
just too much and I just can't take it
I will not surpass this ecstasy this
hilarity this cosmic intensity this
ecstasy and yet everything we want is on
the other side of fear we learned
sometimes the hard way that everything
we feared was all in our minds I know
for me man this is this is what often
kept me from dancing at parties or what
keeps me from rock climbing up cliffs or
downhill mountain biking I fear the
intensity of life lived this close and
yet the greatest moments of my life
ironically have been the ones in which
through made me no fault of my own I
slip streamed into those kinds of
moments when I hurled myself into the
abyss only then did I realize it was a
featherbed and I was like oh my god
I feel old all is good all is great
all's bliss and grace so what have I
learned from this have I transcended
that knowing self-doubt have I
transcended my fears have I absorbed
myself of my neurosis far from it
far from it I've taken steps I've come a
long way I've seen how far I've come and
yet and yet
the journey beckons I haven't fully
heated I feel myself often
second-guessing my decisions stuck not
knowing where my path is ass in so truth
be told I'm a work in progress
these fleeting insights of visionary
understanding these moments of clarity
they nudge me forward right they become
the reference points the anchor points
the tethering zuv where I'm going right
they become a kind of map follow your
bliss said Joseph Campbell and he was
right he was right we'll get there
together